Venus is right here for you to discover
just take a few more steps
suddenly something distracts you from
the first ever first-hand human analysis
of Venus's surface conditions
your protective suit breaks
the DraStic pressure shift would
immediately make you feel like you were
deep underwater
with an atmospheric pressure 90 times
that of Earth Venus would be crushing
you from all directions
at the same time you'd be struggling to
breathe in an atmosphere without any
Oxygen
any atmosphere you did manage to inhale
would scald the inside of your mouth and
the top of your throat
unless you could scramble very quickly
back to the safety of your spacecraft
you'd be dead within seconds